[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in mark sanchez fox nfl
analyst former nfl quarterback and of
course former usc quarterback and he
sits down he's got his uh usc golf shirt
on he's got his brackets there that he's
showing us and mark's doing well in the
bracket challenge right now
but you lost iowa in kentucky so you
lost two of your final four teams still
got arizona and gonzaga
no well i had villanova kansas kentucky
gonzaga so just one final four team
right uh
i got you with kentucky and iowa
wait is this a mistake ton that's the
sheet i got i'll take another look okay
i got uh gonzaga kentucky
uh oh no i printed no no no you're right
you're right you're right i'm printing
i'm in a another bracket with my brother
and his buddies
and i printed the wrong one oh that's my
bad my bad yeah
are you on another race
correct
yeah all the other radio shows
although why are we zooming today we
normally just do a phone call also good
morning yeah good morning i don't know i
i love when we zoom
but
yeah yeah
like okay you know what it makes one of
us it's it's good for this
the only thing that came out of the
pandemic that was good was this that you
got to zoom people
i agree in some ways but the over
zealous zoomers
i'm out
totally out if it can be handled
verbally on a phone call like you have a
you know there's a visual element to
your show yeah obviously keeping todd
off camera is important but you wow you
want to be
you know you got a lot of tchotchkes you
got a lot that the viewers need to see i
get that but when people are like hey
let's jump on a zoom for 20 minutes i'm
like for what
well that bothers me because it feels
like
yeah i i have a problem with that nobody
just calls you on the phone it's got to
be we got to do a zoom
yeah and i so i do have a problem with
that but i think people want to look
busy you know like okay oh did you say
20 20 was the margin got it okay
well
there are times when i'm on the phone
and you hit mute
and you can still hear what somebody's
saying and i can be talking to my wife
or you know i could be doing something
and you know i can't do that on the zoom
exactly yeah 100 yeah yeah all right
well uh i'm glad you're here i wanted to
ask you about baker mayfield at the
point of his career because
you played four seasons with the jets
and then they were moving on from you i
think you're around 26 maybe
and you were a star there in new york
but i was wondering
can you put us in the the position that
baker's in right now that after four
years you're 26
and the browns are moving on from you so
what do you what would be your vice to
him
you know it's
it's just a reminder that this is the
ultimate meritocracy right what have you
done for me lately is there something
better and if you remember uh going into
my third year i want to say
uh it was when peyton manning was
getting ready to you know do his he was
people were shopping him and
seeing what was going on and and the
jets
100 kicked the tires on him i have no
doubt in my mind and
did that bother me of course it bothered
me you know i'm their franchise guy we
had just been to back-to-back afc title
games like we're knocking on the door we
got a shot to really build something
here
and they go
and you know
now in hindsight if i'm the jets hell
yeah i'm gonna go check out peyton
manning hell yeah i'm gonna go look at
his neck and make sure he can play and
bring him in for a workout if he's
willing and all this kind of stuff and
try and keep it under wraps for our
young quarterback so he doesn't get
you know all
uh heard about it but
that's just the way it goes that's the
nature of this business and it's
unfortunate
but that's what you sign up for and and
it's just a
harsh and unfortunate reminder that when
you sign up to play quarterback in the
nfl
you sign up for everything uh the good
the bad the ugly the injuries the
success the failures
for baker um
you know as soon as he knew that that
was gonna happen as soon as he knew that
deshaun watson was a possibility or
whatever
yeah i mean to request a trade you can't
fault the guy i know he's been getting a
ton of criticism but he's a lightning
rod type person anyway right you either
love him or hate him there's not many
people that are lukewarm on baker you
just got to kind of be either way so
i mean what's a what's uh what's one
more headline saying baker wants to be
out like who if i'm baker who cares like
it makes no difference
so
um do you think he's a starting
quarterback next year
somebody will give him a chance to
compete and that's a crappy answer and
i'm sorry because i do
you know i'm too nice with this stuff
but i i
he's tough he's gritty but where where
can he compete for a job do you think
seattle
now i don't know i don't know because
pete's gonna want somebody who can move
a little bit and and that's something i
think um coach carroll has
realized in his time you look at the usc
texas game in the rose bowl you look at
any time he's played a mobile
quarterback like that he understands as
a defensive guy what stresses him the
most we could play the perfect defense
and if russell wilson is going to run
around in the backfield
for six seconds you can't cover for that
long you just can't do it
and there's 53 and a third yards of a
field that you gotta cover and this
guy's running around
like a pinball back there bouncing off
the tackles and spinning and throwing
off his back foot and you know hitting
tyler locket or dk metcalf 35 yards
downfield or behind the line of
scrimmage on the opposite side of the
field now the whole defense has to run
you can't do that so
he knows what stresses him and that's
that's a big point on you know for
defensive head coaches they want on
offense what gives them fits on defense
you know what i mean that's just natural
that you you want something that's
difficult to defend so
i don't know if baker moves enough for
coach carroll
and he turns the ball over too much for
coach carroll so coach carroll's gonna
want great defense great special teams
and a quarterback that can you know lock
in and when we need you to make the
miraculous play go for it kid it's
fourth down let it rip but when it's
time to you know second and ten i need a
completion to get us into a third and
manageable i don't know if he would
trust somebody like that in that
situation now
you know there's something to be said
for him to be groomed into what they
want or molded into what they want but
baker's a pretty unique guy pretty
unique personality he's
you know he's um
i don't know he's he's a he's a
different cat but he's listen his
heisman trophy winner he can't take that
away from me he's the first pick in the
nfl draft can't take that away from him
he's won a bunch of games he took the
browns to the playoffs i mean come on
man he's he's done a couple things that
not just a couple a lot of things that
warrant some you know cachet in this
league it's just are you willing to take
a chance on them and now it's just so
dang late for the guy like all these
spots are getting filled matt ryan just
landed like
the dominoes have all fallen and he's
kind of on the outside unfortunately
looking in so it's
that's a tough spot man i don't i don't
envy that position but he's gonna
i don't know listen when they did the
whole peyton manning thing back to my
you know crappy story for a second
they ended up giving me a a huge
contract i renegotiated after like two
years or three years or whatever and got
a huge payday almost as like a
uh mayor culpa like i'm sorry you know
and so you know i can't complain about
that that's just kind of the way it
worked out
for baker they ended up signing the guy
now if the jets would have signed peyton
manning then i'm out of there you know i
would have went somewhere else well how
how much better are the browns today
well where do they go at receiver that's
because they lose jarvis well they i
think they're trying to get jarvis back
aren't they and they have a maricopa
okay
yeah mari cooper is a huge pickup for
them um you know and that's going to be
desean's guy to bring back jarvis would
be huge if he's willing to take
you know a little bit less and you see
that happening right and and i've heard
you talk about it i've heard coward talk
about it and and it's really the new
the new model is you get one of these
young quarterbacks for cheap
you build up the entire team around them
and after four or five years whether you
pick up their fifth year option or not
then you decide okay is this guy worth
this massive contract and then we're
going to have to dish out all these
other players because we can't keep
everybody so when aaron rodgers takes
that massive deal
devonta adams is standing there like
all right man you know i gotta go get
mine somewhere else it's not personal
it's business i'll see you later and so
when the court look at joe flacco look
at uh you know he gambled like
nobody's business man on that last year
no contract nothing
super bowl mvp super bowl champion signs
the 100 million dollar deal they had to
break up that team and they didn't you
know they didn't have that kind of
success ever again so and that's not on
joe that's you know that's his big
payday he deserved it there's a there's
an argument for that there's also an
argument for the tom brady approach
where yeah could i make 35 could i make
40 am i comfortable with 25 absolutely
okay let's go let's go pick up these
other players that i'm gonna need down
the stretch and not just starters i need
depth i need two million dollars to pay
our backup wide receiver slot who's
our ace on special teams and he's going
to go to a divisional opponent
we need two and a half now not just two
like those kind of decisions factor into
how long you can
play this thing out and how far you can
take your team so
it's uh it's difficult but once you sign
that massive deal it's uh it's hard man
and it's good for those guys they
deserve it but at the same time it's
like okay what what's more important
what's you know what are you trying to
do reverse engineer do you want to win
games do you want to sign a big deal and
then you know reverse engineer it from
there he's mark sanchez fox nfl analyst
uh the broncos with russell wilson if if
we're going to have the hierarchy in the
afc west
uh chiefs
still at the top
you know that's that's interesting i
thought
and it's funny how things worked out in
the afc right like you look at even matt
ryan going to the to the colts like
that's huge they're in a division where
you know it's them in the titans the
titans slightly aging might be you know
time for them to start to turn some of
those pieces over and
you know the colts could could run away
with that division potentially who knows
what happens in jacksonville with doug
peterson first year great quarterback
let's see how that goes
but then he's got to play in the afc who
the hell is going to win that the afc if
you're in the nfc as a quarterback
that's like fast pass that's like you
know carpool lane hov like you're good
just get to the playoffs you might have
to face brady in the championship or
rogers in the championship like
that's where you want to be in the afc
it's bottleneck there and
there's so many good players so many
good teams they just kind of you know
knock each other out and what was crazy
last year is the bengals hang on all
they had to do was get in the tournament
they had the old you know uh new york
jets mentality just get in the
tournament however you got to do it you
got to back in the last day the last
night because the falcons lose and we
win or whatever and indy sits their
players and we win
whatever it takes man just get in so
if you're going to rank them shoot i
mean you got to take the chiefs they won
the division last year um
you know defending division champ give
them the you gotta beat the champ to be
the champ kind of thing so i'd give them
the number one slot but after that i
feel like the charters are right there
man and now with the raiders with their
acquisitions and the broncos with their
acquisitions it's just kind of like one
and then one abc like i don't even know
how you
separate those guys and it's all gonna
it's all gonna play out obviously this
season but that's gonna be the fun as or
all these debates on who's going to be
this who's going to be that i will say
though that
you know i think the broncos might have
won this trade
now
if the seahawks can play this thing
right and i don't know who the hell
they're going to play at quarterback
maybe it's drew luck i don't know
maybe it's uh you know malik willis
maybe they go make a move in the draft
or something and they draft and develop
but
if they can hit on those two ones and
two twos which is hard i mean that's
really hard even if they hit on three of
those four
i mean they might have won this thing
for the long haul because
you know russ is coming off his worst
year he's gonna be motivated of course
he's gonna have you know offensive
weapons he's gonna have a great defense
to help him
but i don't know i mean
this this could be
i think seattle might have won this
thing in the long haul and in the next
five years you look at it it might have
been the right move for them
you're up flying the usc colors are you
uh you're going to practice today
i am going to practice today uh check
out
coach riley and those boys for uh
for the first day of spring practice so
i'm excited for that now were you
invited or you just kind of show up
i always just i i've kept a close
relationship with them i'm like a uh you
know a tennessee tick man i dug myself
in they can't get rid of me wow so uh i
love that place and and they know that i
support them like crazy i was crushed
when they lost their first game of uh
the tournament i was hoping our guys
would show out a little bit but we'll
see
um do you help them recruit
a little bit i mean if they need me you
know
call them up and let them know it's the
best place in the world
no better weather
maybe you talk to the moms i'd use you
for that but i'd have you on a zoom call
[Laughter]
i don't want to hide them i don't want
to hide the moneymaker there sanchez but
all that it's all that
m drive product got me you know i've
been using this stuff i'm looking at you
all right i've been using i've really
actually have been using the brain
whatever so now i'm not just a pretty
face you know now i got the brain
working all six brain cells buddy
i didn't know there were any left after
your uh your day very funny
very funny
you got one more
one more than liner you got one more
than minor hey we played in that flag
football tournament i did all right
uh two weeks ago did you see any of that
no no so rogers they got josh allen
aaron rodgers matt liner
sam darnold me kyle allen and desmond
ritter i think that's eight of us
and we played on these flag football
teams people bid on the quarterbacks
like the first two quarterbacks so
somebody paid like a hundred and ten
thousand dollars for aaron rodgers to be
their quarterback it was for rx3 a part
of roth capital this investment group
that we're all in yeah dude it was off
you should have seen these guys i mean
carson came back out of nowhere
mountain man from idaho finally back in
socal
the fact that they got him out here
shocked me and you know he's like my
idol so i always have to
like you know compose myself before i
see carson but
he was slinging it man him but who was
taking it who took it the most serious
oh as soon as the whistle blew
everybody it was like especially the old
guy older guys i should say but carson
like matt like those
it was like all right here we go the
first game we're kind of feeling
ourselves out like okay do we have any
players on our team by the second game
i mean carson was dropping dying just
whizzing balls by these guys and some
guys were like former players we had
like chris conte dante whitner
um you know
a bunch of dudes and and it was uh it
was really fun but you know you get
these guys that were
you know and venture capitalists and uh
you know
guys who don't really play ball like
they might have played in high school or
whatever but they're just getting their
hands bloodied up by a ball over the
middle from parts of palmer it was
awesome man it was the funniest thing
i've seen in a while that's great that's
great hey it's great to talk to you as
always have fun today at practice and uh
thanks for joining us
yes sir thank you guys all right buddy
that's mark sanchez fox nfl analyst of
course former quarterback at usc and in
the nfl